les philippines connaissent l'une des
croissances les plus fulgurants de
nouveaux cas de vih sur la planète le
pays a enregistré 21 mille nouvelles
affections l'an dernier soit plus du
double qu'en 2015 il existe pourtant un
médicament efficace pour contrer la
progression du virus la prophylaxie pré
exposition où la prep
la pilule consiste en deux agents
antiviraux à prendre quotidiennement
avant une relation sexuelle explique la
directrice adjointe vulgairement to each
existantes en afrique du sud et ancienne
présidente de la conférence
internationale sur le sida il a été
démontré partout dans le monde qu'elle
protège les individus advenant qu'ils
soient exposées au vih
mais une très faible portion de la
population mondiale à risque a accès aux
médicaments mise en marché en 2010 il
nya qu aux états unis en afrique du sud
et au kenya où les programmes de santé
publique long déployée à grande échelle
aux philippines grâce à un programme
financé par des fonds privés environ
3000 personnes reçoivent gratuitement
médicaments c'est bien loin des 100
mille personnes qui devraient en
bénéficier
cette épidémie continuera d'exploser si
nous ne rendons pas la presse accessible
à tous explique son directeur philippe
un d'un programme de prévention
au népal le coût élevé du médicament la
difficulté d'accès aux cliniques et la
stigmatisation font en sorte qu'à peine
2000 des 20000 népalais jugés à risque
utilise la prophylaxie pré-exposition
cela nous attriste parce que de nombreux
utilisateurs de drogues injectables
aimerait prendre de la prête mais elles
coûtent trop chers explique cette
travailleuse de la santé
nous ne pourrons pas vaincre cette
épidémie uniquement avec des traitements
explique-t-elle nous devons encourager
les états et les donateurs à investir
dans la prévention cela ne peut pas être
uniquement l'un ou l'autre
les travailleurs communautaires peuvent
ainsi faire de la sensibilisation et
stimuler la demande pour la preuve
dit-elle on compte 1.9 millions
d'utilisateurs de presse à travers le
monde et l'objectif est de faire passer
ce nombre à 10 millions d'ici 2025 en
attendant la création d'un vaccin d'une
cure contre le vih la prep est considéré
comme l'un des meilleurs outils pour
freiner cette pandémie ici valérie
michaela bayne radio canada montréal